Hey guys, welcome back to the lab, today I thought it would be fun to see
what would happen if we tried putting slime in a vacuum chamber.
But not just any kind of slime, rainbow slime!
This experiment was requested in the comments by Eric Moore.
Eric, thanks for your suggestion, you're about to become $25 richer.
I've mixed up a special concoction in each one of these glasses
and I have another container here with a saturated solution
and if you've seen some of my previous videos you'll know exactly how this works.
So let's pour the solutions together and see what happens.
Ooh, it just gets thick and chunky so fast.
Insta-slime!
There's not much that's cooler than that.
(laughs)
Cool
I'ts working out pretty well.
Wow, those levels are very consistent
Yeah!
Just going to dump out a little of the excess water.
If there is any.
Ha! That sounds awsome.
It's amazing, there's like no left over water.
What a mess. (laughs)
This is looking very good. We've got all different colors of slime.
Now, if you take a very close look at them you can see the slime is filled with bubbles
that was whipped into them when we  were stirring them up.
So this is going to be very interesting to see now when we put them in a vacuum chamber
because as we suck the air out of the chamber these bubbles should expand and make for a really cool effect.
Kinda what I'm thinking here is we'll just take the slime
and pack them into sections and see if we can make like a multi-rainbow colored effect.
and then stick the vacuum chamber lid on top
and press play
There we go.
We'll start
with that on one side.
Okay we'll go orange next.
Yeah!
So if you're watching this video you probably should have a jello cup on hand.
Sweet!
That's kind of shiny,
it's nice, I like that.
Oops we gotta make room for the blue,
before it spreads out you gotta work quick!
There we go.
Cool.
This is the moment, right now when we find out what our slime will do in a vacuum chamber.
Here we go. Let's rock!
Immediately you can see little bubbles popping out of the top.
And it looks like all of the slime is actually rising.
It's pretty much doubled in height there. That's cool.
Ohh my goodness.
Ohh my goodness, look at it go! Look at it go!
WHAT?!
Ahh, I had to turn it off because it was getting too high.
That's crazy! It's turned into like -
It looks like that gel from diapers, colored gel.
Here we go for round 2.
Oh that's so cool. It looks like clown hair, doesn't it?
I'm gonna let in a little air. Oop!
Man, it doesn't take much to set that back in.
Yeah, it's amazing the way it deflates, it turns back to like this chunky gel
and then it liquefies back into a slime. That's very cool.
I'll try letting it in slowly this time.
WOW!
Okay, we have made a rainbow mess all over this thing.
You know what would be cool is if we keep cycling it to the point where all the bubbles actually get sucked out.
I'm not sure if that is gonna happen though cause I think all of the glue is keeping those bubbles.
And just actually maybe even making billions more bubbles.
I mean, look at that! It's like a foam!
You know what's interesting though is that we can't really get the bubbles popping.
And this has increased to like at least 10 times its height. It filled up the entire jar.
And it could go higher, I'm sure.
Look around here, you got like all of the different colors of the rainbow. In gel!
Yeah, look at the side walls here! That has made such a cool-looking mess!
I love it!
You know what this kinda reminds me of, is a snowcone.
It looks like colored snow!
WOW!
That had an audible 'thunk' when I let the air back in!
It was like a "WHOOF"!
It's amazing how grainy the slime looks
after you let the air back in.
Until it melds back into a slimy texture it almost looks kinda gritty!
Oh wow look at this on the side here! Look at this on the side!
It almost looks like ice crystals!
It's like a rainbow ice palace.
It's even sucking the color out of the slime
and just leaving behind this white, gelly residue.
And then the color comes back.
Oh, that's amazing.
So I just shut off my vacuum pump but by keeping this valve closed we can actually maintain our vaccum pressure there.
Now we've run this thing through about 20 cycles
and I can't seem to get it to the point where it sucks out all of the air bubbles
it seems like it just hits this state where it is a perpetual foam
that doesn't really rise very quickly anymore.
So at this point I'm just going to let the air back in
so we can see what happens to the slime after the vacuum chamber experience.
That's so cool.
Like...
Oh wow check this out.
We just made rainbow squishy bath.
Yeah, you can see already after about 30 seconds it's starting to slime back together.
What's really interesting is that I can still see a ton of bubbles in there.
They're just so tiny,
but there's lots of them, look!
Okay, so I'm gonna try and scoop this stuff out.
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, look at that!
It just like pulls right off the container.
BOOM!
(laughs)
Here we go!
So there you have it guys, now you know what slime will do inside of a vacuum chamber.
Very cool experiment, very fun
and makes one heck of a mess.
And thanks again to Eric Moore for this suggestion, if any of you have experiments you wanna see me try, leave your suggestions in the comments below.
Thanks for joining me in this video, I'll be looking for you in the next one
Talk to you then.
Oh, there's a cute shot, in the top-down there. (laughs)
That looks like something inappropriate.
I really like this vacuum chamber.
Hey guys, thanks for watching, and remember I'm giving away prizes now on every new video.
All you have to do to qualify is subscribe to my channel, ring the bell, and select to be notified when my next videos get released.
The secret link to my giveaways will be pinned in the comments for the first twelve hours.
If you like what I'm doing, show your support right now by giving this video a big thumbs up
and share with a friend. I love you back, and I'll see you next time.